nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour heureux de
vous retrouver ce matin sur rtl france
alors comment comprendre les
déclarations du chef de l'état eh bien
on peut dire qu'eric zemmour les rendent
tous fougères où il dit c'était déjà le
cas rappelez-vous pour michel barnier le
parangon du fédéralisme européen qui
s'est levé un matin en se disant devant
son café tient la souveraineté juridique
de la france c'est vachement important
quand même pour les républicains
européiste un d eux c'est du pareil au
même et entre deux engueulades il nous
ressort le vieux discours sarkozyste de
l'ordre et la politique au kärcher même
valérie pécresse sur la question
européenne commence même à contester la
primauté du droit européen c'est
formidable et maintenant mais sûre c'est
au tour deux candidats macron de
retourner sa veste de costard pour faire
une table me jirik de la france de la
nation de la souveraineté de
l'indépendance de la puissance française
et même mêmes de la démocratie
il permet de nous les français quel
honneur tout cela ressemble un salto
arrière magistrat auquel emmanuel macron
ne nous avait pas habitués de goal sors
de ce corps alors j'ai réécouté ce long
monologue version pastorale électorale
où il est entouré d'un parterre de
fidèles à qui il a égrainé la recette
magique et technocratique d'une france
qui gagne mais en regardant bien je n'ai
pas vu il ouvriers ni de caissier arni
d'artisans et encore moins de j'ai les
jambes l'assistance apparemment
apparemment la france périphérique
n'avait pas reçu d'invitation ou son
pass politique n'était pas valide avant
2030 olivier mais c'étaient des
étudiants a pas a priori mais pourtant
et emmanuel macron a fait de nombreuses
annonces durant cette prise de parole
peut-on retenir selon vous
magali que du lourd comme disent les
jeunes que du lourd seul avec mes veines
timide honte pour nous français habitués
à la rigueur budgétaire ou pas sanitaire
ya de gros cordon sécuritaire pour
encadrer les manifs à leur peine mais
alain on nous refait le coup du défi
climatique alors même qu emmanuel macron
et 7 t'énerver du silo plus lorsqu'il
s'agit de signer quoi avec tous les
traités de libre échange et un traité de
libre-échange comme le ceta magali c'est
à trop éco responsable lorsqu'on fait du
commerce avec le canada avec des
milliers de supertankers très polluants
qui nous livre en trois duport bourru
d'antibiotiques garantie sans contrôle
alors pour répondre aux défis
climatiques il va falloir trouver autre
chose que la libye des hectolitres au
fioul après le candidat candide macron a
fait un petit laïus sur la capacité de
la france à rebâtir les terres d'une
indépendance productif française deux
fois france dans la phase 1 j'ai parlé
déjà mille fois ici de nombreux plans de
délocalisation et de licenciements en
france réalisée en cours et à venir et
j'aimerais j'aimerais porter ce matin la
tension notre chef de l'état stratège la
situation à vernon dans l'autre del
normandie où la production du moteur
ariane 6 va être délocalisée ou en
allemagne suite à un accord avec qui nos
voisins germaniques alors on peut pas
dire que ce soit le meilleur accord du
monde car cela va causer 600 départs
volontaires qui ont pour la plupart
pointer à pôle emploi on est quand même
loin de loin de la magie de l'industrie
chanter a capella par agnès pas dire une
hache et la marie chantal des prolos
comme la surnomme nos confrères de
marianne ensuite nous en nous on doit
aussi un petit couplet sur l'innovation
et alors là mais alors là je me suis
régalé ce fut un sommet de la novlangue
théocratique technocratique par mon mac
row nist et je ne peux m'empêcher ce
matin nous faire part de cette
étouffe-chrétien cet axe iq et je cite
ouvrez les guillemets bâtir les termes
de crédibilité qui nous permettent
d'accélérer les bâtiments publics dans
l'innovation l'innovation de rupture et
de croissance plus loin seul moyen de
construire des éléments de modernisation
sectorielle qui va nous permettre de
baisser la mauvaise dépense c'est à dire
la dépense curatives alors bon les
mourres les comprends ça c'est ok mais
j'ai quand même l'impression magali qui
n'ont pas été mis dans le bon ordre ou
alors que le conseiller qui a pendu ça
oubliez de faire la mise à jour de
google traduction car ça ne veut
absolument rien dire emmanuel macron
aussi évoqué l'hydrogène vert et
l'installation de ga factory
d'électrolyseurs de ces 2030 alors même
que la priorité absolue me semble que ce
serait plutôt d'avoir une centaine de
doliprane davance et de pouvoir compter
sur un labo pharmaceutique sérieux et
indépendante qui en soit en capacité de
nous pondre un truc si ça venait se
gâter néanmoins le chef de l'état a
annoncé un plan santé innovation 2030
alors même que la france à fermer des
milliers de lits de rennes depuis le
début du coc vide mais l'innovation pour
emmanuel macron s'est détruite vite avec
pas grand chose il a fait quoi ils
appellent cela la tartine de chénerilles
et nicolas est ce que cette prise de
parole pourrait s'apparenter à une
entrée officieuse en campagne
présidentielle ah ben voilà la question
qui tue chez olivier oui clairement
carreman emmanuel macron il ya un an
campagne présidentielle c'est assez
clair surtout depuis qu'il a sorti le
chéquier à tout bout de champ alors
qu'il peut alors encore plus lorsqu'il
déclare être le premier coup tva le 1er
gaulois réfractaires en référence à sa
déclaration un brin méprisant comptes
2008 depuis le danemark en réalité
manuel mâcon a toujours vu la france
commune aux grandes entreprises mais au
bord de la faillite dans laquelle il
faut quoi il faut réorganiser
rentabiliser licenciés flexibiliser pour
l'envoyer dans la fournaise de la
mondialisation car il est toujours
emmanuel macron skos killer qui a une
location airbnb à l'elysée néanmoins
avec la situation sociale explosive et
la hausse des carburants de
l'électricité et du gaz il ne faudrait
pas que le projet 2030 devienne une
banqueroute en 2022 allez sur ce je
retourne à ma lecture du nouveau livre
sur le maquereau 10 mhz dont le titre
est le traître et le néant de gérard
davet et fabrice lhomme avant de
regarder quoi la saison 2 des gilet
jaune et ben vous souhaite une bonne
lecture nicolas vidal choix que vous
allez vraiment ça y est c'est de retour
en france ça tombe bien ça pourra
soigner